- But what's been the craziest
moment like on onstage?
I've had a lot of crazy ones,
do you ever think--
- Oh yeah!
- things go absolutely wrong?
- All the time,
my sister Estee can never, you know,
she trips constantly.
- always, she trips co- -Oh no.
- I don't know why, but she does,
there's so many videos of
her in the internet falling,
but I think for me,
(Kelly laughs)
it's hilarious.
But by the end of tour, I
remember it was our last show
and for some reason me
and my siblings decided
for this whole tour
that we were gonna wear
these leather pants
which is- I don't- if you're
ever gonna go on tour-
- You were sweating.
- Oh, shvitzing?
- Yeah.
- to my core.
- And, I really do not recommend it.
And these pants was they'd had no give.
And I remember specifically
right before the show,
because it was our last show.
We like packed everything up
and it was like already on the bus.
So, like I had no other clothes
and I don't know what I did,
but like, I might've like
got low or something,
and the back of my pants
just completely split open.
- This has happened to me!
- No.
- Since You've Been Gone music video!
- Stop!
- My whole ass was hanging out.
- Oh my God! Me too!
- Yeah, whole ass, not even just a little.
- And I didn't know. Yeah!
- Just big old butt behind. Yeah!
Just big old behind. Yeah!
- It's the craziest feeling.
- Yeah, there's a draft. There's a draft!
- Yeah, exactly there was a draft!
- Oh my God. I can't believe
this happened to you.
- Oh yeah.
- You were on stage?
- I was on stage.
And because I was like,
oh, okay. I'll just go.
I'll just like run off stage
and then come back on with like new pants.
But I realized that I
had packed everything
and it was like far away.
- What did you do?
- I just kept going and
I didn't turn around.
- We have different size asses.
That's not a possibility
for me. (Kelly laughs)
- Oh no. I was just like.
If I get through this,
I'll, it'll be fine.
I'm just going to get
through it. But like I fully,
I think it was just like,
I've never been more
stiff in my whole life.
I was like holding my guitar.
- You're Beyonce. You just keep going.
- Oh, I kept going.
- Oh my god. -And going.
But it was terrible.
I will never wear leather
pants on since then ever again.
- But here's the thing, you
might've never turned around
But the rest of the band and crew-
- Oh yeah. They got a show.
The got the best show.
(Kelly laughing) They got the
best tickets in the house.
- I love that you kept going!